[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission consacrée
aux élus du coeur les élus du cœur se
sont de mer qui mobilisent leur ville
leur population et qui se mobilisent
même pour venir en aide à une
association formidable qui s'appelle
mécénat et chirurgie cardiaque mais
c'est la chirurgie cardiaque c'est une
association qui permet de sauver la vie
d'enfants qui sont atteints de
malformations cardiaques qui ne peuvent
pas être opérés dans leur pays d'origine
qui sont rapatriés en France et opérés
et sauvés ici bonjour
Cédric Cédric papa
Monique bonjour vous êtes le maire de
Villepreux alors les élus du cœur c'est
essentiellement vous mais il y en a
d'autres aussi qui sont avec vous quand
je disais c'est vrai vous avez beaucoup
mobilisé
les populations de vos villes et puis et
puis et puis vous vous êtes mobilisés
vous-même pour sauver au fond deux
enfants la vie de deux enfants on va y
revenir mais il y a une actualité dans
votre mobilisation qui est très forte ça
va se passer à partir du lundi 26
septembre c'est le Half Marathon des
Sables que vous allez faire vous-même
alors expliquez-nous ce que c'est que ce
half Marathon des Sables
contrairement à ce que son nom pourrait
laisser penser le Half marathon c'est
pas un semi-marathon on part pas pour
non on part pas pour 21 on part pour 21
+ 100 puisque on part sur une distance
de 120 entre 100 et 100 km dans le
désert des Canaries oui effectivement et
alors ça se passe en plusieurs étapes
ça se passe en plusieurs étapes ça se
passe en trois étapes il y a une
première étape 30 km dès le lundi matin
puisqu'on arrive le dimanche soir on
part dimanche on est briefait le soir on
a on a le road map le soir du dimanche
savoir vraiment comment on va
s'organiser cette course et
théoriquement par lundi matin pour 30 km
on dort dans le désert on bivouac le
soir le mardi on part pour 40 ou 60 km
il y a une option à choisir
petit bifurcation j'essaie d'orienter
vers le 40
allez-y des folles généralement vous
pouvez orienter le
regardez parce que c'est pas fini il
vous a déjà entraîné dans cette aventure
mais c'est pas tout il entraîne aussi
son père il est en train de son père il
lui a vendu la chose à peu près comme il
me l'a vendu en disant on va faire un
half marathon sans la précision qui vous
a apporté en début d'année
vous a pas dit sandwichs votre père
Alban il a quoi il a choisi une
soixantaine d'années et là les 60 il a
atteint les 60 cette année ouais ouais
donc c'est aussi quelque part un petit
cadeau peut-être empoisonné j'en sais
rien d'un petit cadeau d'anniversaire et
ça va être sympa de partir ensemble
aussi c'est vrai que vous allez faire
équipe enfin il faut tout dire les uns
les autres parce que c'est pas c'est pas
évident de courir 30 40 ou 60 km dans
une journée
ouais il faut avoir le physique il faut
avoir le moral quoi
on y va on y va pas non plus en touriste
ça fait quelques semaines quelques mois
qu'on s'entraîne physiquement une
préparation physique et puis après il y
a toute la partie qui est pas
nécessairement visible mais qui a été
très chronophage et qui fait partie de
la préparation c'est toute la logistique
puisque comme Cédric le disait on part
en bivouac vous avez un petit sac à dos
ouais on a un sac à dos qui va approcher
les 8 à 10 kg puisqu'on porte l'eau
alors il y a des réveils évidemment
[Musique]
et surtout dans le sable ouais c'est ça
et en plus c'est dans le sable mais
alors oui dans ce sac à dos il y a quoi
il y a vos c'est pas du V pour dormir
l'eau il y a tout ça il y a l'eau c'est
des sacs à dos équipés spécialement pour
la course donc il y a l'eau qui est
portée sur les deux épaules il y a de
quoi tenir un subsister avec à manger la
nourriture lyophilisée aucun plaisir
qu'on découvre
juste avant mon conseil municipal de
lundi soir
j'avais un petit creux donc j'ai testé
les potes bolognaise le test était
plutôt concluant
c'est pas de la grande cuisine c'est pas
de la grande gastronomie mais ça fera
l'affaire de toute façon oui là je pense
qu'on doit avoir faim et puis voilà il
faut c'est vrai que vous pouvez pas vous
charger beaucoup plus vite 8 kg
et donc oui il y a tout ça il y a des
petites barres de non des petites barres
énergétiques de quoi s'hydrater
réellement plus de l'eau le duvet le le
sac de couchage le matelas on a un petit
matelas qu'on va fixer en dessous qui
est pas très épais mais qui évitera de
d'avoir le dos bloqué le lendemain matin
faut quand même qu'on ait des tentes
individuel
qui sont sur c'est la seule chose il y a
deux choses deux choses qu'on ne porte
pas ce sont les tentes et l'eau alors
l'eau il faut évidemment qu'on est
constamment de l'eau avec nous mais il y
a des ravitaillements pendant la course
ce qu'il faut c'est bien anticiper avant
le départ chaque matin d'avoir de l'eau
avec nous puisque première réveilment
est à 10 km donc il faut pas partir à
sec le matin d'accord et le sac à dos
c'est c'est parce qu'il faut pas que ça
ça tape comme ça sur le nom sur le dos
ou sur le on a profité des courses
d'entraînement qu'on a faites les semis
semi-marathon mais là des vrais semis
qu'on a fait sur les dernières semaines
et puis quelques courses aussi libre de
30 km ou un peu plus pour ajuster ces
sacs à dos là pour s'assurer justement
c'est très important ça et donc là vous
vous sentez au point quoi
sera le jour J quand on non en tout cas
je pense que Cédric partage mais là
l'excitation
regardez les jours passés là alors il y
a des petits détails on en parlait tout
à l'heure par exemple c'est du sable en
effet alors les chaussures c'est des
chaussures particulières ou des
chaussures de course à peu près normal
il y a un peu tout type de terrain il y
a du sable il y aura de la roche on est
quand même sur les Canaries donc c'est
assez le vocal volcanique aussi et donc
on a des chaussures à la fois très
légères mais qui se on a veillait à ce
que le sable ne rentre pas par contre on
aura des guêtres on a des guêtres
effectivement
j'ai déposé les trois paires ce matin
chez un cordonnier qui nous a été
recommandé par une collègue élue qui a
fait cette course l'an passé à
Versailles et donc on récupère les
chaussures là prochainement donc il faut
les coudre parce que le sable par
définition il se met partout et c'est la
première nous expliquer que les premiers
motif d'abandon sur cette course là
c'était les blessures aux pieds liées au
sable qui est rentré dans les rencontres
c'est vrai alors il faut il faut dire
quand je disais vous vous disez on en a
la preuve mais il y a beaucoup de gens
qui se mobilisent avec vous il y a
notamment tous ceux qui vous aident à
trouver le matériel vous le fournir
c'est important
je voudrais vraiment remercier notre ami
Laurent qui est le gérant de l'endurance
shop de Bois-d'Arcy qui vraiment est
quelqu'un d'assez extraordinaire c'est
une belle rencontre et donc il nous a
fourni gracieusement pratiquement tout
l'équipement on part avec des bâtons
avec des duvets nous on avait déjà nos
chaussures mais aussi sur la nutrition
il nous a accompagné donc on a des
dotations de partenaires je pense à la
marque baoo à la marque taille énergie
qui nous permettent d'avoir des petites
barres de céréales des petits des petits
gels aussi
à prendre de temps à autre et puis
l'hydratation enfin voilà tout ce qui
nous permettra aussi de compenser les
sels minéraux qu'on va perdre lorsqu'on
va transpirer sous les 30 c'est quelques
degrés ouais Decathlon pour les repas
aussi Décathlon pour les repas tout à
fait Décathlon pour les repas Décathlon
plaisir donc sur le territoire là ici je
les ai contactés parce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler chez eux il y a
quelques années et mon ancien
responsable chef de rayon montagne était
encore là donc quand je lis au téléphone
il m'a dit bah banco on vous fait une
dotation donc voilà
ils le font aussi parce que c'est vous
et puis parce que c'est possible mais
chirurgie cardiaque on va on va on va
parler après vous avez pris des conseils
auprès de de gens qui ont fait ces
malentendu sable
on a eu l'occasion de prendre quelques
conseils notamment une élue de Audrey
qui est élu à Poissy
l'an dernier l'année juste avant et qui
est revenu avec quelques conseils qui a
bien voulu partager avec nous quelques
conseils qui nous seront bien utiles
pour s'assurer de terminer la course
dans un état correct vous étiez des
marathoniens enfin des avant de partir
dans cette aventure autant jadis
quelques semis de manière régulière et
puis de manière plus espacée avant de
reprendre sérieusement d'entraînement
pour pour ce défi là
j'ai fait le mon premier marathon le
Marathon de Paris je l'ai fait cette
année en avril dernier bon ça c'est pas
trop mal passé mais je suis j'ai plus
d'affection pour
course course à pied sur sur route c'est
pas ce qui me branche le plus mais voilà
on a déjà couru
de toute façon
de se lancer dans une voiture comme ça
et votre votre père mon père fait
beaucoup de sport il a repris la course
à peu près en même temps que moi j'ai
croisé il est bien ouais c'est plus
affûté des trois je pense
en tout cas il a beaucoup de fonds
grands randonneur grand marcheur il fait
beaucoup de vélo voilà je sais que quand
il est justement dans son entreprise le
midi il fait il fait du sport aussi donc
les les
populations les gens de Villepreux de
Port-Marly ils le savent évidemment que
vous allez faire ça comment il vous
comment il voit ça ils sont fiers il y a
un réel engouement il y a il y a de
vrais soutien c'est vraiment c'est une
aventure qui dit l'amitié
que vous avez ensemble depuis des années
qui est pas si fréquente que ça dans le
monde dans lequel on évolue mais une
amitié réelle la famille avec Alban qui
vient et puis vraiment des rencontres
avec des personnes au grand cœur on sent
que dans nos populations il y a ça il y
a ça aussi qui est nourrit elles ont
tout de suite adhéré au principe à
l'aventure et donc cette aventure
finalement la vie avec tous ce monde là
autour de nous ce qui nous donne une
énergie folle là pour alors ce qu'on
attend avec impatience parce que tes
vaisseaux étaient partenaires de votre
de cette opération vous allez nous
envoyer des images voilà vous nous direz
dans quel état vous êtes chaque soir
comment ça se passe qu'est-ce qui a été
qu'est-ce qui vous a surpris qu'est-ce
qui était plus dur que ce qui était plus
facile peut-être que vous ne le pensiez
ça va être génial ça va avoir le
presque en temps réel vos réactions donc
nous aussi on intervient
vous partez dimanche alors ça permet de
dire qu'il y a eu déjà beaucoup
d'actions dimanche
il y a le concert chez vous à Villepreux
tout à fait alors c'est une action en
plus qui se veut dans la prolongation
des journées du patrimoine puisqu'on va
être accueilli dans un magnifique
morceau de patrimoine de la ville qui
est le domaine de Grand-Maison qui est
un domaine privé et donc les
propriétaires nous font et bien
l'honneur et le plaisir d'ouvrir leurs
portes gracieusement pour un concert du
cœur au profit de mes Sénat chirurgical
c'est la maîtrise de trap de
l'association de promotion de de la
musique en quartiers prioritaire qui qui
sera là et donc là oui ça va être un
beau moment
hors-sautoshin d'ailleurs sera présent
le directeur général de messe cardiaque
et le Fils et le fils on parlait
d'histoire de famille il y en a une
belle aussi au sein de mécénat entre
Orso et sa maman qui est la fondatrice
effectivement donc c'est le dimanche à
18h30
ça c'est une des actions parce que
derrière tout ça derrière votre
mobilisation derrière le le
marathon des sables
il y a l'idée c'est de récolter de
parce que opérer vous voulez le but
c'est de sauver deux enfants un par
ville au fond il faut trouver combien ça
coûte à peu près combien 20000 euros
c'est ça un peu plus 24000 euros par
enfant c'est ça donc l'idée c'était de
récolter 24000 euros pour sauver ces
deux enfants deux villes pour devis
et donc il y a eu des ce concert en
études il y a aussi un dîner de gala
avec des ventes notamment de tableaux
aux enchères avec avec des gens qui sont
venus qui étaient extrêmement généreux
tous et qui a vous a permis de récolter
9000 euros 9000 euros on fait 9000 euros
sur le gala qui s'est tenu aux pyramides
où là aussi on a été accueilli chez
Cédric
dans la ville dans la ville
et c'est vrai que déjà on était assez
heureux parce que on a réussi à
rassembler des personnes de milieu et de
raison vraiment différent oui il y avait
des chefs d'entreprise
des personnes qui venaient à aucun titre
juste qu'on était voilà qui sont
retrouvés dans notre démarche et donc
9000 euros collectés sur ce gars ça veut
dire que rien que le gars c'est presque
un enfant de sauver et donc moi je doute
pas qu'on arrivera à faire les deux il
reste encore un petit effort à faire
mais on arrivera à atteindre
on peut dire ça peut dire ça il y a une
autre chose qui est très importante je
disais mais c'est de la chirurgie
cardiaque sauf des enfants qui ne
peuvent pas être opérés dans leur pays
d'origine parce que ils ont pas il y a
pas les les moyens médicaux et
techniques
donc il faut les accueillir en France il
faut des familles d'accueil ça c'est
très important d'en parler parce que bah
c'est pas évident de se dire je vais
accueillir un enfant ça dure combien de
temps à peu près l'accueil plusieurs
mois plusieurs mois entre deux à quatre
mois le temps voilà de l'accueillir de
préparer l'opération les suites
opératoires
Francine Leca qui est cette femme
formidable qui était le premier
chirurgienne cardiaque femme en France
et qui est spécialise dans le
chirurgicardique des enfants
elle quant à leur parle avec tellement
de d'Allons et de et de patio que c'est
formidable dit c'est je crois que c'est
vrai les familles d'accueil une fois
qu'il voit que l'enfant qui est au prix
en charge a été sauvé ils ont un plaisir
un bonheur
indicible presque
mais mais il faut il faut trouver il
faut trouver ces familles il semblerait
qu'il y en ait une de trouver à
fort-marder déjà il y en aura
certainement une qui a été
identifiée à l'occasion du gala parce
qu'il a été organisé aux pyramides
Alexandre fenghold qui nous a fait
l'amitié nous recevoir donc le lecteur
absolument le propriétaire des lieux
propriétaire et
il se pourrait que son épouse il
accueille ils accueillent un enfant
il va le mettre dans les pyramides
une piscine formidable
ça c'est génial je disais ça parce que
c'est vrai que des gens peuvent hésiter
quoi
ce qui se comprend mais mais je crois
que d'après tous les témoignages qu'on
peut recueillir c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que le bonheur que reçoivent ces
familles est très fort il y a eu
d'autres actions au fond l'histoire a
commencé parce que vous avez rencontré
la fondatrice de Messenger cardiaque sur
une table du Tour de France qui passait
à Villepreux c'est ça en fait on a la
chance depuis quelques années d'avoir le
tour qui passe dans notre village et au
moment où la caravane passe je vois
cette voiture logotée mais c'est là
chirurgie cardiaque qui tourne qui sort
en fait du parcours qui d'ailleurs va
direction grand maison là où on
accueillera le concert et j'étais avec
quelques élus à ce moment-là on se dit
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
voiture qui sort de donc on a en tant
qu' élu on fait notre boulot on
interpelle je crois même qu'il y avait
un agent de police municipale avec nous
donc on commence un petit peu à discuter
et puis donc il y avait hors-saut qui
était au volant et puis madame le cas
Francine qui était à côté on papote un
petit peu tout de suite il y a un
feeling et on dit il faut qu'on se
revoit et donc on s'est vu quelques
semaines après à la mairie de Villepreux
et là c'est vrai que ça a été un coup de
cœur ils m'ont présenté leur association
et donc je me suis dit il faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose avec eux on est
parti d'une petite idée qui était de
dire que la ville proviennent qui est
cette course qu'on a chaque année à
Villepreux qui d'ailleurs cette année
sera au profit mais on s'est dit on va
commencer par ça et puis on s'est dit on
va peut-être faire autre chose et puis
comme j'aime pas faire les choses seules
et que quand il y a des idées folles le
premier que j'appelle c'est le collègue
d'à côté je me suis dit on va pas faire
un an une ville pour un enfant on va
essayer d'aller un peu plus loin et
faire deux villes pour deux enfants donc
c'est parti de là c'est parti d'un
hasard de la vie où on s'est croisé sur
les routes du touret Cédric vous avez
tout de suite dit oui quoi je ne résiste
pas à chaque fois voilà je qualifie deux
fois le ces idées mais j'allais repart
particulièrement puis surtout celle-ci
alors là on est à quelques jours de
votre de votre départ vous êtes
impatient évidemment
faire gaffe pas attraper de rhume comme
ça après être en pleine forme quand vous
arrivez
aux Canaries
oui et puis je dirais que la période de
la rentrée scolaire dans le cadre de nos
fonctions est quand même
particulièrement dense c'est pas sans
sujet cette rentrée pour les
collectivités donc là on met les
bouchées doubles pour que les dossiers
soient
clos soit en tout cas mis en stand-by et
traité en tout cas voilà mais bon on a
des on a des on a des équipes qui vont
pouvoir prendre le relais pendant 4
jours il y a pas de difficulté là-dessus
mais c'est vrai que entre là
donc la préparation physique
l'organisation de logistique et puis nos
fonctions parce que
on bosse quand même c'est vrai que c'est
assez on a l'impression d'avoir commencé
la course avant avant même là de d'y
être et vous avez imaginé quand vous
allez courir à ce que est-ce que vous
allez passer à autre chose vous allez
dire merde
dossier là il faut que je le traite
absolument vous avez pensé à vous à vos
ennuis de merde aujourd'hui mais enfin
parfois il y a des problèmes
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on court on
pense à rien ou pour des petites choses
l'objectif est là actuellement c'est
vrai que ça permet de vider la tête
alors les premiers kilomètres peut-être
qu'on aura encore ce type de pensée je
pense qu'après l'ambition et c'est
mental qui permet de terminer les
courses on sera focalisé focus sur
l'objectif et la mairie sera au moins
tempérament et les autres activités
temporairement
là où elles sont c'est-à-dire loin des
Canaries c'est vrai que au bout d'un
moment on pense à ses pieds
c'est vrai que à juste titre on y va on
y va évidemment pour cette cause mais on
y va aussi parce que on est dans des
fonctions où on peut avoir la tête dans
le guidon en permanence et c'est
important de temps en temps de lever un
peu le nez et moi je sais que quand je
cours quand je fais quelques courses un
peu longues j'arrive à déconnecter et va
être pleinement dans
apprécier la course et puis
l'environnement dans lequel on est donc
là ça moi j'ai pas de doute sur le fait
qu'on arrive à déconnecter quelques
jours
je vous dis merde ouais on peut dire
et puis on vous enverra des petites
vidéos alors on sera peut-être pas
forcément très propre parce qu'il y aura
pas de montage
c'est de savoir comment ça se passe et
puis voilà on croise les doigts on
souhaite le meilleur et bravo merci
beaucoup on dirait bravo quand on
reviendra merci
[Musique]